when I was on the first time the I had  seen the show but I didn't really look  it up I didn't know you guys created and  so I remember like oh they're really  letting us improvise a lot I kept saying  they and I'm like yeah I hope they use I  hope they use that yeah and you guys yes  you're really saying that yes and we  were like yeah no we will yeah yeah we  will I don't think anyone knew until you  started reading it how funny that resume  was  so for you for several years I've been  in complete charge of pretty much  everything in my life that's actually  that was okay  okay uh 2005 to 2006 education odd jobs  here and there  yeah we're hearing this we're hearing  all things  oh I was just reading things off the  resume but I thought you guys wrote that  no no so I thought you were laughing at  the stuff you wrote themselves I wasn't  doing anything okay  [Music]